Great.
This conversation is going to look like
a conversation about public speaking
because it's,
it's pretty formalized and that I'm
standing up here at the front of the room
and you are sitting in audience mode,
but this is a really,
this is really about the image that you
project and that can be one on one or
around the conference room table or
standing up to give a presentation.
But this is about inspiring
confidence in your abilities.
There are some people just in the
way that they carry themselves.
You immediately have faith
that they can get the job done,
whatever the job might be.
And some people do it with a big bold,
dynamic personality and some people
do it with a very calm down to earth
demeanor, but whatever the
style, you just believe in them.
The fallacy is that those
kinds of positive assessments
that we make about other
people,
that they're all very subjective.
They're based on nuance store
or indefinable criteria.
And I've spent the last 20 years of my
life researching how human beings assess
other human beings. And the bottom
line is that there are ground rules,
there are metrics,
certain behaviors lead to very
predictable assessments on the part of the
listener.
So if you can better understand what
behaviors lead to what assessments,
you can just be more in charge of the
image that's coming across on the other
side.
Are you aware that certain facial
expressions are hardwired into us?
Not all facial expressions, but certain
core facial expressions like fear, joy,
anger,
grief,
and it's why we can read
facial expressions across
cultures or why babies can
read facial expressions
at a very early age. Well,
the same thing is true for
your body language signals.
A significant portion of
your body language signals
are what we call universal,
how human beings assess
other human beings.
And so I'll give you an example of one,
keeping your head level.
So literally being levelheaded is a
show of confidence across the globe.
Wherever you go.
Now,
whether you should show confidence is a
value system and sometimes that changes
from culture to culture.
Sometimes in some cultures
being deferential is a far
better way to do business.
But being levelheaded as a show
of confidence wherever you go.
If I raise my chin just a bit,
this is a very high status position to
be in and if I continue to speak to you
with my Chin just a little bit high,
you are very likely to find me a
little condescending, little arrogant.
Can you see that?
If I lower my chin just a bit,
this is a very low status position to
be in and if I continue to speak to you
with my Chin Low, you're very likely to
find me a little shy or differential.
And especially if I tilt my
head now whether or not I
personally am aware of the
position of my chin,
because I could be oblivious to what's
happening up here is still having an
impact on your side and even on your side,
you're not consciously aware of what
behavior is sending the message because it
just happens so fast in there.
So if I had started today with my chin
up like this and said, hello everybody,
I'm very excited to have this
opportunity to talk with you.
You would all begin to make an assessment
of me really quickly and in your exact
adjective would be up to
you, but you would all be
leaning in the same direction.
But it is doubtful that any of you would
have identified that it was my chin
that was bothering you.
I mean you wouldn't leave
afterwards and say, you know,
Kira was okay but her chin,
it was so high you just be stuck
with your assessment of me.
So that's why it's my job as the speaker
to be very aware of the signals that
I'm sending out I because they're having
an impact whether I am aware of them or
not.
And have you heard studies about how
long it takes for someone to come up with
an assessment of you under
30 seconds seconds? Right.
So seconds.
I recently read the research
from Millenium Body and
she was highlighted in the
book blink by Malcolm Gladwell,
but she is the researcher who
coined the term thin slicing,
which is our ability to see a pattern and
just a very thin slice of information.
When one of her research projects,
she showed people videotapes
of individual strangers.
She hadn't them assign adjectives that
they would use to describe the person on
the screen. And at first she showed
the video tapes for two minutes,
but then she just cut back and cut it
back and she got down to two seconds and
she found that the adjectives people
would use to describe the stranger on the
screen were the same whether they had
the opportunity to see the video tape for
two minutes or for two seconds.
Now,
that's pretty amazing actually. It's
amazing on two levels. First of all,
it's amazing that it happens so quickly,
but more importantly for
today's conversation,
it's amazing that there's
general agreement.
When we watch a video tape of a stranger,
we will all use about the same
adjectives to describe that person.
So if that is true,
they have got to be ground rules.
And so that's really what the
credibility code is all about.
What are the ground rules?
What are these behaviors?
How much impact did they have?
How much control do you have over them?
Now I had the pleasure to have worked
with Google over the last few years.
So I know a good deal about your,
your culture and in a
workshop early on in the,
one of the things that comes up is a
conversation about authenticity because
there's a high value here on being
authentic. And I want to acknowledge that.
And first of unsupported, I want you
to know, I believe that you are first,
you're going to be at your
best if your first yourself.
And that is really great if you have
some strong speaking skills on your side.
So I want you to think about the
ground rules that I'm about to lay out,
like the rules of punctuation or grammar.
As a writer,
we don't feel inauthentic in our writing
because we're following the rules of
punctuation and grammar. And you
wouldn't say as a writer, well of, well,
we're all following the exact same rules.
How will my unique voice
come through so well?
The truth is if you aren't following
the rules of punctuation or grammar,
people aren't like to pay
likely to pay attention to you.
And there are some really talented
people who can break the rules.
So that's acknowledged that too.
And it just makes them more interesting.
I give you permission to
break the rules to too,
but break the rule because you know
the power of it and you choose to do it
differently as opposed to just being
oblivious to how that behavior might might
come across.
All right.
I broke the conversation up into three
sections. First, what I call the basics.
And these are those behaviors that
you need to do just to get those,
those basic level adjectives where
someone might describe you as comfortable,
competent, capable, credible. Uh,
of course you want that as your baseline.
And then we'll talk about those things
you shouldn't do. I call those derailers.
So those behaviors that are
almost always invisible to us,
we don't know that they're going on,
but they nonetheless undercut our image.
And then I'll talk about the perfect
balance between being authoritative on the
one side to being
approachable on the other.
And the best communicators of all
know how to do both at the same time.
And just to give you a quick preview,
I will show you what it's like to lean
too heavily in one direction or the other.
If you're using a lot of authoritative
behaviors and I just kicked into a few
more of them right now, you're very likely
to come across as capable, competent,
and expert. But if you rely
too heavily on these behaviors,
you could also come across
as unreceptive or inflexible,
which isn't going to help you create a
relationship with the person on the other
side.
On the other end of the spectrum,
if you're using a lot of approachable
behaviors and I just kicked into a few
more of those right now, well you're very
likely to come across as interactive,
personable,
maybe even dynamic,
but if you rely too
heavily on these behaviors,
you could also come across
as a lightweight nice,
but in consequential.
So you need to have a balance between
both sides and if you personally know that
you need to bolster one end
of the spectrum or the other,
I will give very specific behaviors
that tend to send those messages.
Okay.
Going back up to the top.
The very first thing someone notices
about you as the visual picture.
So your body language has a big impact
on your appearance of credibility and
confidence.
The three pillars that hold up
your appearance of leadership,
presence of credibility,
of personal presence are strong posture,
strong voice,
strong eye contact.
If you're doing those three things, you
are going to look good. Strong posture,
strong voice,
and strong eye contact.
Now most people have heard some
version of this advice before. It's,
it's not like it's brand
new concept out there,
but most people severely underestimate
just how important those behaviors are.
So let me be explicit.
Strong posture means that
if you're standing up,
your weight is balanced equally over
both feet and whether you're seated or
standing,
your spine and your shoulders form
a t like a like a metal t bar.
And this area right here is rock solid,
has literal core strength.
So notice how if I allow myself to have
just a little more wishy washiness in my
spine,
I lose a lot of my executive presence.
So you have literal core
strength through here.
Then your head and your
shoulders move independently.
So your head moves like
a camera on a tripod,
which means I can look over here and I
can look over here and I can look over
here.
What's not happening is this,
again I'm back to wishy washy or
being a little kid in trouble. Oh,
think about how eagles and
owls survey their surroundings.
We call them regal and wise.
And then one word,
your nose has to point directly
toward the person you're speaking to.
So if I'm looking at you,
my nose points directly toward you.
And if I look at you,
Notice what happens in my eyes. Move a
little more independently of my nose.
I'm very likely to look uncomfortable,
but I could also look sneaky or
mischievous or judgmental or skeptical.
Have you heard the phrase looking out
the corner of your eye at someone?
What does that mean?
Reticent Questioning.
So if you want to come
across as straight forward,
you have to literally be straight on
with the person you are speaking to.
There's a concept in communication
that is called marked and unmarked
communication.
And ultimately what we're trying to do
with our body language signals is unmark
the communication so that the
power of our words take precedent.
Sometimes we're sending some accidental
signal that sends a mixed message.
And so let me give you an
example of how this played out.
Recently I was working
with a group of teenagers,
actually a group of young mothers
in a job placement program.
And one of the young women said to me,
parents and teachers say that I show
attitude and I don't get what they mean by
that because I really don't
feel like I show attitude.
But she said it to me like this.
Okay.
Parents and teachers say that I
show attitude and I don't get,
you need to straighten that out. So if I
look at you this way, this is unmarked,
straightforward communication.
Me just talking to you.
And as soon as I start
to move my Chin around
in Mark's the communication. So if
you want to unmark the communication,
so people will really
hear what you have to say.
You need to be literally
straight on direct. So,
so here's the takeaway in
this particular section.
If you want someone to describe you as
having a strong spine and a level head,
you need to literally have a
strong spine and a level head.
And if you want someone to describe
you as straightforward and direct,
you have to literally be
straightforward and direct.
It is pretty amazing how the language
we use is a literal translation of the
attribute we are describing.
So standing with your weight balanced
over both feet, how might you describe me?
Grounded, balanced on
solid footing, upright,
strong spine from backbone, levelheaded,
head square on my shoulders,
standing on my own, two
feet, not easily pushed over.
There are so many positive metaphors here.
Fully evolved.
So you want to make sure,
oh and let's take some negative metaphors
being a slouch or shifty or unbalanced
or crooked.
So you want to physically embody the
metaphors you want people to use when
describing you.
All right.
Now if you just learned in
this conversation that you
should stand stock still,
well that would be a problem
too because part of leadership,
presence of looking perfectly
comfortable is fluidity.
Owning the space around you.
So your core provides the solidity.
And your hands and your facial gestures
provide the fluidity, the interactivity
hand gestures are or they're
hardwired into all of us.
There are a form of communication that's
that's deeper and older than verbal
communication. Then I'm even blind
people gesture when they speak.
It's not something we learn visually.
It's hardwired,
but what is most interesting about hand
gestures is that they are an unconscious
process, which means when you
are not thinking about it,
your hands are very much engaged in the
conversation and as soon as you become
self conscious, as soon as you
begin to think about the hands,
you have no idea what to do.
These bandages at the ends of your
arms and that that when that happens,
we tend to go into some sort of lockdown
mode or I call it unmasking masked mode
and it it's that apparent
self consciousness that
gives away the fact that you
are intimidated or
nervous by the situation.
When we are perfectly comfortable,
our hands talk when we talk,
if you want to exhibit executive presence,
personal presence,
the second year mouth begins moving.
Your body language has to talk to because
what intimidation looks like is your
mouth is moving, but no other body
language signal is online yet.
You don't have to learn
how to hand gesture.
You just your hundreds upon hundreds
of times throughout the day.
It's not a skill you need to learn.
What you need to learn is not to mask.
Not Too.